the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi today we start a new segment of our
course it could be entitled techniques
of integration and a subtitle could be
the difference between knowing what to
do and knowing how to do it you see
essentially in this chapter it shall be
our aim to develop various recipes to
say to evaluate the inverse derivative
so in fact let's call it that some basic
recipes the idea is something like this
let's start with an easier problem let's
suppose we start with a differentiable
function G suppose for example that G
prime is equal to F then in terms of the
language of the indefinite integral or
the inverse derivative what we have is
that the indefinite integral of f of X
with respect to X is then G of X plus C
now you see the harder problem is the
inverse of this you see what we're going
to be talking about is how not how do
you find F once G is given but
techniques for finding G once F is given
and as we've seen on several occasions
already that given F it is not that easy
in general to find a function whose
derivative is f in fact in many cases we
can't do it as explicitly as we would
like to no matter how sharp we are for
example oh I'll just review this search
you can think of this in one block given
F the required G may not exist in
familiar form I don't want to pin down
what familiar means any more than that
right now for example the illustration
that we've used several times already in
the course suppose f of X is e to the
minus x squared and we want a function
whose derivative is e to the minus x
squared in terms of areas the second
fundamental theorem of integral calculus
we can construct such a function in a
rather straightforward way even though
it may be difficult to name it in terms
of familiar functions namely what we do
is is we take the curve y equals e to
the minus T squared in the Y T plane
compute the area bounded above by that
curve below by the Tea Act
on the left by the y-axis and on the
right by the line t equals x and the
area under the curve is a function of X
and what we've already seen is that in
this particular case a prime of X is
precisely eetu the minus x squared in
other words this area function which is
a function of X does turn out to be the
function whose derivative with respect
to X is e to the minus x squared
Macie that will not be primarily what
we're interested in in this particular
phase of our course what we're
interested in this phase of the course
is given various classifications of the
function f to find recipes that will
give us G in familiar form where G is
the function whose derivative is f in
otherwise summarize for you to look at
here the objective of this block of
material is to find recipes for finding
g of x for various types of f of X now
the best way to illustrate what that
means is to actually pick a few examples
and by the way what you'll notice in
today's lecture is roughly speaking we
do nothing at all that's new the new
stuff will begin with our next lecture
essentially but for now what we really
be doing is giving us an excuse to pull
together all of the recipes that we've
developed so far all of the recipes for
either called indefinite integrals or
inverse derivatives for example the
lodger the first class of functions
which we could handle were things of the
form integral u the MD you recall that
very earlier in our course we found out
that the integral of U of the MD you was
U to the n plus 1 over n plus 1 plus a
constant if n was unequal to minus 1 and
then in our last block of material we
learned to handle the the case where n
was equal to minus 1 namely when n is
minus 1 integral U to the minus 1 du u
namely integral D u over u is natural
log absolute value of U plus a constant
now this then is one of our basic
building blocks what we're saying is if
an indefinite integral can be written in
this form we are
we have a recipe that allows us to
evaluate the integral by the way with us
also point out as we've mentioned again
several times in the past that U is the
generic name for a variable over here it
is not important in this recipe that we
use you what is important is that
whatever is being raised to the M power
inside the integrand must be precisely
the thing that's following the D over
here for example is it a few suppose I
used sine x over here well it was
suppose I had sine X to the M power D
sine X see what's being raised to the
nth power is the same thing as what's
following the D see that's all I really
care about in other words if this had
been the recipe then if this had been
the integrand the recipe would have said
this is 1 over n plus 1 times sine X to
the n plus 1 power plus a constant if n
is not equal to minus 1 and it's natural
log absolute value of sine X plus a
constant if n is equal to minus 1 see
again the important thing is not to you
but the fact that what's being raised to
the nth power is the same as what's
following the D over here by the way we
can write this in more familiar form
you see namely notice that the
differential of sine X is cosine X DX
and consequently in this form what our
recipe says is that integral sine X to
the nth power times cosine X DX is given
by this in other words it's sine to the
n plus 1 power x over n plus 1 plus a
constant if n is unequal to minus 1 and
it's the natural log absolute value of
sine X plus C if n is equal to minus 1
again notice this
this looks more complicated than this
but to get our problem to get into the
form you to the nd you notice that the
natural substitution here is to let u
equal sine X in which case D u would be
cosine X DX in other words the extra
factor of cosine X here actually is to
our advantage over here that when we
make the substitution that gives us the
form that we want with the fact that
missing we're in a little bit of trouble
by the way this is what makes this a
rather exciting topic that there seems
to be no really canned ways of finding
indefinite integrals that we have
recipes frequently the recipe that we
have doesn't cover the situation that we
have in fact I know a lot of times in
teaching a course like this students say
why do we have to learn these recipes
and techniques why can't we just look
them up in the tables and the answer
quite simply is that in many
applications the integral that we have
doesn't appear in that form in the table
that frequently what we must do is a
tremendous amount of algebraic
manipulation and the like to even get
the given integral to resemble one that
we can find in the table oh we're
starting off on a fairly straightforward
level here nothing really too tricky but
at least enough still we get an idea of
what kind of gimmicks are involved for
example suppose we had cosine X to the
seventh power DX you see the idea is
that when you have cosine raised to a
power it would have been nice if a sine
X Factor had been in here because you
see the differential of cosine X is
minus sine X DX and what I'm driving at
here is that we often have to have a
certain kind of ingenuity that allows us
to reduce a new integrand to a more
familiar one and as I say there are many
techniques done in the textbook there'll
be plenty of exercises again that will
allow you to experiment on this all I
want to do is hit a few highlights and
create the mood as to what's going on
for example you see frequently what
happens is if we have cosine X raised to
an odd power a very convenient way of
handling this is to split off one of the
factors of cosine X separately
in other words write this as cosine X to
the sixth power times cosine X DX the
idea being that cosine squared can be
written as 1 minus sine squared in other
words cosine X to the sixth power is
really cosine squared X cubed but cosine
squared X is 1 minus sine squared X in
other words notice again the role of the
truth dimetric identities I take this
integrand write it this way and now you
see if I use the binomial theorem and
expand this notice that my typical term
will have sine X to a power multiplied
by a cosine X and that's precisely the
kind of a term that I handled in the
previous case you see and again I'm not
going to bore you with the details here
that is the easiest part of the problem
the hard part is getting to understand
why one would want to use this
particular kind of form Oh another
variation is what happens if the cosine
is raised to an even power rather than
to an odd power how do we handle that
and again the same kind of use of
trigonometric identities for example one
it would not be to our advantage in this
case to replace cosine squared by one
minus sine squared because then we would
wind up with the same kind of integrins
that we started with only using powers
of sine instead of powers of cosine you
see the idea is that if we have a power
of sine we want a cosine factor to
accompany it and inversely if we have a
power of cosine we'd like a factor of
sine to accompany it why so that we can
get the integral into the form use the
ndu in this particular case a very
common device is to invoke the identity
that cosine squared of an angle is 1
plus cosine twice the angle over 2 you
see again this is where all these
particular identities come into play
it's not a case of saying let's learn
these identities so that we can recite
them it's a case of getting into a
situation where you want a certain
answer can't handle it conveniently in
the form that you're in and hope that
you can pick off a synonym that allows
you to tackle the problem most
successfully that's where this becomes a
matter of insight lucky guessing skill
whatever you want to call it you see
it's one thing to transform an integral
into an equivalent one and another thing
to have that equivalent integral be
something that you can handle well at
any rate for example in the problem of
this type a tendency is to write cosine
sixth theta as cosine squared cubed
cosine squared theta is one plus cosine
two theta over two to cube this we can
take out the factor of one eighth you
see we use the binomial theorem to
expand one plus cosine two theta cubed
and notice that the terms that we get
this term we can handle this term we can
handle is just cosine to the first power
which involves a sine term when we
integrate and here's the cosine cubed
but we've just seen how you can handle
something to an odd power so that
reduces this term to a type that we can
handle and then we see what that we have
another term in here which is cosine
squared to theta that's an even power of
cosine again we do what we write cosine
squared to theta as one plus cosine of
twice this angle that's one plus cosine
four theta over two in other words we
keep reducing these things always hoping
to break them down into collections of
problems that we solved before and as I
said these are things that will drill on
in the exercises and I think it will
become more meaningful they're here as I
say the main aim is to create the mood
that what we're trying to do is to
reduce unfamiliar problems to equivalent
familiar ones to which we already know
the answer now again in the way of
review sometimes an integrand occurs in
the form of the sum or difference of two
squares
we've already handled this in terms of
the inverse circular functions and the
inverse hyperbolic functions it's
covered for the first time in our
textbook at this particular stage of the
course and I think it's a tough enough
concept so that it's worth emphasizing
at this stage so I just separate this
particular type out how do we handle
sums and differences of squares and what
I intend to show is is that by a
suitable
a metric function either circular
trigonometric or hyperbolic
trigonometric we can always reduce that
kind of a problem to the type that we
can handle again to keep computation at
a minimum I have not tried to pick a
rather complicated situation in fact
I've picked ones where you can eat very
easily look them up on the table if that
was the main aim of the exercise you see
here it's not so much that I want to get
this answer as much as this is what I
want to spend emphasize the technique
that one uses the idea is something like
this here we see the difference of two
squares it's the square root of a
squared minus x squared what this should
do for us is to suggest a right triangle
whose hypotenuse is a and one of whose
sides is X that's the diagram I've drawn
over here this is my reference triangle
as I say we've done this before but I
would like to reinforce this at this
particular stage especially now that
we're more familiar with both the
inverse circular and inverse hyperbolic
functions at any rate we use this
reference triangle from this triangle
the easiest relationship to pick off
involving X is that sine theta is x over
a or a sine theta equals x from which it
follows that a cosine theta D theta is
DX the square root of a squared minus x
squared over a is cosine theta therefore
the square root of a squared minus x
squared is a cosine theta if we now make
this substitution in this particular
integral we wind up with integral DX
over the square root of a squared minus
x squared is equal to integral d theta
which is theta plus C and since theta is
the number whose sine is x over a we
have that the answer to this problem is
inverse sine x over a plus a constant
again just a straightforward review but
a rather important technique in our
textbook this is put in a separate
section and the technique is called
trigonometric substitution and I just
wanted to show you what motivates the
trigonometric substitution the harder
part as I mentioned in our previous
lecture is how you motivate
trigonometric substitutions when it's
the hyperbolic functions that are
you see what I'd like to do now is
instead of dealing with the square root
of a squared minus x squared
let me just reverse the order of the
terms and now let me take integral DX
over the square root of x squared minus
a squared notice that the difference
between x squared minus a squared and a
squared minus x squared is just a factor
of -1 and the fact that minus 1 is under
the square root sign really means in a
certain manner of speaking that you've
multiplied by I the square root of -1 to
transform the integral that we just had
into this particular form here and in
terms of our lecture around the
hyperbolic functions
that's a should in some way give us a
preview of things to come
in the sense that the hyperbolic
functions are very strongly related to
the circular functions my technique for
doing this and again this is highly
subjective it's very simple I learnt the
circular functions long before I learnt
the hyperbolic functions consequently I
feel very much at home with the circular
functions as a result whenever I see the
sum or difference of two squares I
always think in terms of a triangle I
make a circular trigonometric
substitution if that works for me fine I
haven't lost anything if it doesn't work
for me it gives me the hint that I can't
seem to get in my own mind without this
hint as to which hyperbolic function I
should use let me show you this in terms
of this particular example if I saw this
problem from scratch and didn't have any
past previous knowledge of how to handle
this I say ah this seems like I should
think of a right triangle whose
hypotenuse is X and one of whose sides
is a so I think of this particular
reference triangle now thinking of this
triangle and in fact even looking at
this triangle I very easily pick off
then X is equal to a cosecant theta see
x over a is 1 over sine theta that's
cosecant theta therefore and remembering
how to differentiate the cosecant I take
the differential of both sides and I
find that minus a cosecant theta
cotangent theta d-theta is DX again from
this diagram I see that the square root
of x squared minus a squared
is well let's see the square root of x
squared minus a squared over a would be
cotangent theta so the square root of x
squared minus a squared itself is a
cotangent theta making the substitution
in the integral DX over the square root
of x squared minus a squared notice that
the A's cancel the cotangent cancel and
I'm left with cosecant theta d-theta and
a minus sign inside my integral in other
words somehow or other this circular
trigonometric function replaces the
integral DX over the square root of x
squared minus a squared
by integral minus cosecant theta D theta
and the point i'd like to emphasize at
this particular stage is that we don't
say that the substitution has failed the
substitution has been made we have
replaced an integral involving X by one
involving theta it's just that in the
same way that it's difficult to
integrate secant theta in fact that
would be later in this block of material
we'll do that but the point is that
secant and cosecant are rather difficult
functions to integrate in fact at this
stage of our development we do not know
a function whose derivative is cosecant
theta consequent we don't know one whose
derivative is minus cosecant theta we
seem to have arrived at an impasse here
we have successfully made the
substitution but the key point is that
the new integral is no easier for us to
handle than the old integral now his how
I visualize the hyperbolic substitutions
we do this in the last lecture I think
it's tough enough so I'd like to do it a
second time and give you a chance of
seeing how easy this is once you see the
structural form notice that the
substitution I made here was x equals a
cosecant theta the cosecant was the key
step here the reference triangle knowing
how to draw this geometrically allowed
me not to consciously have to think of
the trigonometric identities but what I
really did in evaluating this problem if
I left the diagram out and wanted to do
it analytically the identity that I made
use of was the one that said cosecant
squared theta minus cotangent squared
theta is identically 1 in other words I
would like an identity
for the hyperbolic functions that has
the structure that the difference of two
squares is identically 1 the easiest one
I can think of is the one that says cosh
squared theta minus sin squared theta is
one
you see structurally these two are
equivalent in other words cinch and cosh
are related hyperbolically the same way
that cotangent and cosecant are in terms
of circular functions the identification
is this since in the original problem
I tried x equals a cosecant theta and
since the identification here is that
cosecant and cosh are matched up when I
try next see once this has failed I very
quickly now say ok what I'll do is
instead of x equals a cosecant theta
I'll try x equals a cos theta that's
exactly what I did over here AE equals a
cosh theta equals x from which it
follows that DX is a cinch theta d-theta
the square root of x squared minus a
squared is just a squared cosh squared
theta that's x squared minus a squared
that can be written as the square root
of a squared times the quantity cosh
squared theta minus 1 now the
interesting point is that cos squared
theta minus 1 turns out to be sin
squared theta fact if one just look back
here for a moment recall that's exactly
what we have over here that cosh squared
theta is 1 well cos squared theta is 1
plus sinh squared theta cos squared
theta minus 1 is sin squared theta and
you might say wasn't that terrific what
a lucky break it was that this
complicated expression just happened to
be sin squared theta and now taking the
square root I get a cinch theta the
thing I'd like to point out is that the
element of luck was removed from this at
the instant that I recognize the fact
that caution Cinch were related by the
same identity that cosecant and
cotangent were in other words I rigged
this thing so that when I finally had to
take this particular difference
I had to wind up with an easy
we're root to extract you see I had the
right structure to begin with
at any rate to make a long story short
here DX is a cinch theta d-theta the
square root of x squared minus a squared
is a cinch theta therefore DX over the
square root of x squared minus a squared
well look how nicely this works out the
a sinch theta cancels from both the
numerator and the denominator and it
turns out that the integral I'm looking
for DX over the square root of x squared
minus a squared is just theta plus a
constant
but now recalling that a cosh theta
equals X in other words cosh theta is x
over a and therefore theta is inverse
cosh X over a I arrive at the result
that this integral is inverse cosh X
over a plus a constant in other words
what I hope that these two little
examples show is that when I have the
sum or difference of two squares the
trigonometric substitutions will usually
give me a crack at getting an equivalent
integral that will be easier to handle
what may happen is that the circular
functions won't help me but the
hyperbolic ones will or vice versa and I
hope that you see how these are so
delicately connected well there is one
final type of technique that I would
like to show for today's lesson that's
related to what we've already done and
with that we'll conclude today's lesson
and go into some more elaborate recipes
next time but this is a take-off on our
old high school construction of
completing a square in other words let's
suppose we have an expression of the
form ax squared plus BX plus C and this
may sound old hat to you you may
remember this as looking pretty much
like the development of the quadratic
equation you see the idea works
something like this first of all I can
factor an a out of here I'm assuming
that a is not zero in fact if a was zero
I really wouldn't have a square term in
here I factor out an A and I'm left with
a times x squared plus B over a X plus C
over a now it turns out that whenever
you have something of the form x squared
plus something times X
to convert that into a perfect square
and again we'll have ample opportunity
to practice this and the exercises you
take half the coefficient of x and
square it see half the coefficient of x
here is B over 2a if I square that it's
B squared over 4a squared
now to keep the identity intact here if
I add in B squared over 4a squared
I must subtract that in other words I
just add and subtract this term that
will make this a perfect square in fact
what is x squared plus B over ax plus b
squared over 4a squared you'll notice
that this is just X plus B over 2a
squared see x squared just multiply this
thing out you see how this particular
thing works in other words what I've
done is I can write this as a times the
perfect square and by the way what's
left over here if I multiply these two
terms through by a this is C minus B
squared over 4a in other words
recognizing that this is X plus B over
2a squared and multiplying these two
terms through by a I wind up with the
fact that ax squared plus BX plus C can
always be written in this particular
form this is called completing the
square
notice that this is now a perfect square
and this is some constant and the
question that comes up is what does this
have to do with integral calculus in
other words with finding antiderivatives
and again as is so often the case and
granted that as this course especially
this chapter gets more complicated the
degree of sophistication will become
much greater but the basic idea will
always remain the same somehow or other
we will always try to reduce a new
situation to a more familiar one in
other words let's suppose now we don't
have an integrand that's the sum and
difference of two squares but we have an
integrand that involves a quadratic
expression say for example we have DX
over ax squared plus BX plus C well you
see using hindsight rather than
foresight I already took care of this
problem before we started namely we just
finished completing the square over here
namely what is a
x squared plus BX plus C notice it can
be written in what form let's come back
here and take a look it's a times X plus
B over 2a squared plus some constant I
don't care what it happens to be here
I'll just call that constant C sub one
and by the way notice depending upon the
relative sizes of a B and C this
constant can be either positive or
negative or in fact even zero so to
handle that without a is I can always
write this denominator in the form a
times X plus B over 2a squared plus or
minus some constant where I'm assuming
now that the constant is positive that's
why I put the plus or minus sign in its
plus some positive constant or else it's
minus some positive constant now what I
can do is factor an a from the
denominator if i factor out an a from
the denominator here I have 1 over a
times a certain integral what integral
DX over X plus B over 2a squared plus or
minus still some some constant in other
words I had c1 here I factored out an a
c2 is actually c1 over a and I just
factor out an a from this thing here but
it doesn't make any difference the
important point is I now have this
written in this particular form now if I
assume that C 2 is a positive constant
notice that any positive number is a
perfect square namely it's the square of
its square root and again as I say with
the exercises this will become clearer
when we work with specific numbers but
the idea is what this is some perfect
square which I'll call K and in other
words this integrand can now be written
in the form 1 over a DX over X plus B
over 2a squared plus or minus K squared
well again what am i leading up to if I
now make the substitution that u equals
x plus B over 2a
notice that my denominator simply
becomes u squared plus or minus K
squared in other words my denominator
now has the form of either the sum or
difference of two squares on the other
hand if u is X plus B over 2a what
do you remember DNA our constants B over
2a is a constant the derivative of a
constant is zero so D U is equal to DX
in other words notice that if I now make
this substitution in here outside I have
a 1 over a inside I have D u over u
squared plus or minus K squared in other
words when I have a quadratic I can
write that in the form the sum and/or
difference of two squares simply by
completing the square okay
simply by completing the square in other
words I can solve the problem of the
quadratic by converting it back into an
integral the type of which I've solved
before and this by and large becomes a
technique that we use throughout this
chapter well at any rate I won't go into
that in any more detail right now we
will pick up additional techniques in
our next lecture and until the next
lecture goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate